oh how do you say that some people don't
have to establish basis of that empty
warehouse I think there's a girl revenge
boys or whisper ten-year-old okay okay
no gender is not disconnected from sex
so hopefully so okay no it is not in the
mind okay you're not a man if you think
you're a man and I didn't say pretending
or if I did I shouldn't have said
pretending let me imagine okay I said a
boy who thinks he's a girl let's see the
usual phraseology I use not playing I
usually say boys think he's a girl over
a thing is a point which is technically
what we're talking about here as far as
the actual psychological issues at play
it used to be called gender dysphoria
nor gender identity disorder another
college gender dysphoria the idea that
that sex or gender are malleable is not
true okay and I'm not denying your
humanity if you are a transgender person
I am saying that you are not the sex to
which you claim to be you're still a
human being and you're a human being
with an issue that I'm you know I wish
you Godspeed in dealing with in whatever
way you see fit but if you are going to
dictate to me that I'm supposed to
pretend I'm supposed to pretend that men
are women and women are men know my
answer is no I'm not going to I'm not
going to modify basic biology because it
threatens your subjective sense of what
you are okay I'm saying that the Boy
Scouts have a standard you must be a
biological boy to be a Boy Scout you
have to be a boy to be a Boy Scout in
the name Boy Scout
because it because it because this is
because this is a very important because
for all of human history boy mint boy
and girl mint girl boy did not mean bro
and if I call you a moose are you
suddenly a moose okay if I redefine our
turn no it's a yes that's right men and
women are a completely different thing
this is true have you ever met a man or
a woman no completely - why's that I
don't understand why okay let me ask you
to tell okay I won't ask you how old I
will ask you how old you are okay
because you're young enough it's
probably not insulting to ask you so
know why aren't you 60
why aren't you 60 and what
why can't you identify a 60 why would
what what is the problem with you
identifying a 60 you're right age is
significantly less important than gender
you can't magically change your gender
you can't magically change your sex
you can't magically change your age
people can't legally change your age by
the way just because you can do things
legally doesn't mean that they are
correct biologically to do lots of
things in the past that were incorrect
biologically incorrect legally for a
long period of time in the United States
sterilization of the mentally ill took
place that didn't make it okay skin
reverses Oklahoma justice Oliver Wendell
Holmes wrote the decision it's not a
matter of open-minded and accepting I
want them to get treatment that they see
fit that's not involving me the idea
behind the transgender movement as a
civil rights movement is the idea that
all of their problems would just go away
if I would pretend that they were the
sex to which they claim to which they
claim membership that's nonsense
the transgender suicide rate is 40
percent it is 40 percent and according
to me according to the Anderson School
UCLA it makes no difference
they just started came out last year it
makes no difference virtually no
difference statistically speaking as to
whether people recognize you as a
transgender person or
which suggests there's a very high core
morbidity between transgenderism
whatever that mental state may be and
suicidality that has nothing to do with
how society because of their holiness no
I don't think that I do not think that
the discrepancies I do not think the
discrepancy first of all I'm against
bullying of any sort okay the idea that
somebody would beat somebody up is
terrible okay and somebody who's
viciously bullied in high school I'm not
a fan of bullying but the idea that the
normal suicide rate across the United
States is 4% the suicide rate in the
transgender community is 40% the idea
that 36% more transgender people are
committing suicide because people are
mean to men is ridiculous it's not true
and it's not backed by any science that
anyone can cite it is pure conjecture in
fact it's not even true the bullying
causes suicide according to a lot of
studies those for example in the black
community where the idea is supposedly
at America's a racist society blacks are
bullied a lot okay in the black
community lacking a significantly lower
suicide rate than the white community in
fact in third-world countries the
suicide rate is significantly lower than
in first world countries suicide
actually seems to be a privilege of the
upper classes if you actually look at it
from a financial perspective so the idea
that suicidality is directly a result of
people like me saying no men are not
women and women are not men it's not
true it's also all of your question I
think the idea that you're going to
sacrifice the entire societies proper
definition of sex because you think that
there is a in legal term somebody with
an eggshell skull meaning that somebody
who has a pre-existing condition that
makes them more susceptible to criticism
that that is not a way to run a society
you can't sacrifice truth because some
people are going to actually suffer
because of the truth plus there's no
evidence whatsoever that the suicide
rate would go down and the transgender
community in any market way if people
just started pretending the men were
women and women Ramon we're trying that
experiment now we'll find out whether it
works so far no evidence although this
group of like 20 people I'm more than
happy to talk to a group of any people
who will have me but usually they
protest me
last question all about our tender home
why do you think it's not about
composing with bodies and problems ever
lifelike afters 84th how can people hair
up and they don't care we're down to
foster care after all commodity poor
okay I do care about the mother being
poor I do care about foster care because
I what Planned Parenthood doesn't
prevent abortion is one hundreds of
thousands of abortions year they perform
300,000 abortions a year they're leading
abortions in the United States that they
perform 300,000 abortions a year from
Planned Parenthood that's my evidence
they don't have that no I'm not anti
birth control birth can hold is burger
legal they're not the only people in
America who provide affordable birth
control you can go get a pack of condoms
down at the local CVS or twelve box yes
and it's true that most forms of birth
control are also extraordinarily cheap
on an annualized basis unless you have a
severe problem those most birth control
is very cheap and readily available and
I'm not against people going and getting
that from Planned Parenthood as you may
have noticed I'm mostly against abortion
if you're under planned parent care I do
care when you start killing babies this
is a problem for me oh so this is it
okay so Jerry's election I mean there's
a long conversation I'm enjoying it
actually which is why I'm allowing you
to stay but it is but it's but the
question of rape and incest first of all
important to know rape and incest are
not only a vast minority of abortion
cases they're an extraordinarily low
percentage of abortion cases so if we
can first stipulate that all the other
abortions are bad then we can talk about
that other one can we do that are all
the other abortions better those ones
okay and you're just using this as an
excuse to make the other ones okay okay
ah good someone who's honest so
who's the honest fellow okay yeah honest
people good I like the honesty okay so
all abortions are okay so does it shows
so Oh a sign that I can't read because
it has lots of words on it okay so I
have one question for you and one
question only on abortion does the
vagina the vaginal canal magically
confer personhood answer does the vagina
magically confirm personhood
yeah raised hands are okay you sir you
know the first breath it draws the first
breath can first personhood okay so if
the baby is in the womb and is exactly
the same size and has not yet breeds and
you take a knife and you stabbed the
baby in the head they fully form nine
month old baby it is not a human the
only thing that makes it a human is want
to take the breath and have to
independently breathe I mean I'm going
to be honest I'm gonna stick to it gasps
because I'm also true capital punishment
and prose selective suicide so I'm going
to stick with selective suicide yeah I
assume you know I send me no elective
suicide okay
I'm not going to come make something hey
that's good because that wouldn't be
suicide every homicide and so so that
that by the way I'm for a capital
punishment too because people who kill
people should be killed but babies who
have not killed people should not this
is my basic position on abortion so let
me just so but I'll get your answer
could you the one who asked the question
are you going to stipulate that all the
other abortions are bad just rape and
incest bother you I mean so it's an
excuse right so it's an excuse that we
can say that oh so that we can we can
take the marginal case and then say the
DES marginal case applies to all cases
okay that's that's again faulty thinking
but if you want me to answer
specifically on rape and incest here is
my basic answer rapists should be
castrated or killed you shouldn't kill
babies end of story
I agree and that's usually left side of
the aisle because website wants to let
them out after five years in prison
I want them castrated or killed I'm
telling you what my belief is my belief
is not public policy at the moment but I
think would you agree with me on that
one can we least get a little agreement
to finish this particular parlay date
you should rape us be castrated kill oh
okay good yeah are we agree Thanks